with alien covenant out on blu-ray a
stack of new footage is now available
including a bonus scene that reveals
David's plans for an alien queen UPK
movie lovers it's Jan here and in this
video I'll be explaining a brand new
epilogue scene with new connections to
the original first and second Alien
films plus what will likely be seeing in
the alien covenant sequel
I'll also run through many of the
official blu-ray deleted and extended
scenes and explain some the gaps from
the theatrical release that they help
fill in all so I'm starting a brand new
Funko pop giveaway for an alien covenant
Funko pop from this range to enter the
giveaway subscribe and leave a comment
with your thoughts on the movies bonus
or deleted scenes just before I start a
quick warning that I will be discussing
spoilers so take care if you haven't
seen the movie yet rights let's kick off
with a bonus scene Advent a six and a
half minute short film which serves as a
kind of epilogue to the movie it begins
with David transmitting a secure message
to the weyland-yutani corporation david
says his extending an olive branch to
the company which immediately opens up
all sorts of questions about what
exactly has happened between David and
the corporation between the end of the
movie and now for him to be trying to
reconcile with them for example have
they discovered his lies about the crew
dying in the neutrino blast or did they
find out he was impersonating Walter at
the close of the film as David talks we
get to see lots of details with workshop
and experiments he's been conducting on
the paradise planet in the message David
explains he's been exploring space
following Peter Weyland vision and that
together with Elizabeth sure he found
the engineer planet which he described
as a rotting paradise
david says he wiped the planet clean as
a gift to shore and that he wanted to
build a new civilization with her help
however she refused it seems that after
bombing the planet with a deadly
pathogen David woke her up and she was
presumably horrified at his actions
David has this totally creepy way of
very matter-of-factly talking about
something that's actually truly
horrifying it explains that he had no
option but to use Shaw's body parts to
make his masterpiece of course David's
actions and the way he talks about them
are disturbing enough as it is but if
you think back to the prologue short the
crossing which shows David talking about
how Elizabeth sure showed him such
kindness
I'm basically putting back together
after the events of Prometheus what
David dozen says in Advent becomes even
more chilling David believes the
engineers were too afraid of their own
power which is clearly not a problem he
showed and although both he and they
were creators of what he calls the wolf
and the lamb the engineers were too
scared of their aggressive creation
Davidson explains that as he researched
the black goo he discovered it was ripe
with advance nanoparticles and functions
according to an algorithm based on
evolutionary computing he also describes
the living organism as a form of radical
and chaotic artificial intelligence
which is interesting because it ties in
with Ridley Scott's belief which he'd
mentioned in interviews and his
director's commentary that in the real
world both AI and alien life could be
potential threats to humanity
David elaborates on his discoveries
revealing that the pathogen adapts to
each species of living organism uniquely
and alter this idea explains more
details about what he's recorded the
video flashes through various images
with one image in particular revealing
that the fourth generation has a
shortened gestation period additionally
that his creations have a hide like
minds that connects them to a common
goal now this mention of a hive or the
common goal is a clear connection to the
idea of an alien queen which first
appeared in James Cameron's aliens movie
the sequel to Ridley Scott's original
alien David explains that he didn't find
the animal life on the engineered
planets suitable enough to fully develop
his alien creation the thirty discovered
short human body was a much better host
which he used to finally develop what he
called his wolf the video then jumps
back to the Covenant ship to remind us
as David says that he now also had his
flock of lambs in other words the ship's
human cargo who have uses fodder for the
continued creation of his masterpiece
and experiment and next we get the
biggest T for what coming up in the next
sequel when David says that he's still
working on perfecting his Queen then his
hand touches Daniels cryo chamber as
this first message ends David
triumphantly states that this is going
to change everything
so we've got a big tease here from
Ridley Scott for the follow-up movie to
alien covenant that either Daniels will
be the source of David alien Queens or
possibly even that she'll be transformed
into
and it'll be interesting to see whether
Scott will link her in some way to James
Cameron's alien Queen from aliens
especially given there were some visual
similarities between the Queen from
aliens and the elongated head of the
xenomorph we saw David develop an alien
covenant and also given the fact that in
David's note which we see in the advent
sequence he mentioned the hive mentality
more importantly though I imagine for
Scott we'll be linking up all the
prequels to his own alien movie which
kicked off the franchise in 1979 so I'm
guessing we'll be getting an explanation
for the source of all the eggs on the
derelict where they first appeared in
that original movie I'm just theorizing
but I wonder whether David discovered
that female human eggs or the perfect
host for developing as alien creation
because in Advent explains that there
was something extraordinary about the
substances reaction to the human genome
and that he was able to unlock new
properties and tweak the organisms
aggression and instinct for survival
also interesting is at the start of each
of these four transmissions is labeled
with a special order code all of which
precede special order 937 which was the
directive from weyland-yutani to ash we
saw in the first Alien movie special
order 937 stated as an astronomers
primary objective was to collect and
preserve the alien creature discovered
in that film and the ship's crew was
considered expendable if necessary the
special order seen in Advent suggests
that David was in regular communication
with weyland-yutani about his research
and that the corporation's discussions
with him led them to consider the alien
species and extremely valuable potential
bioweapon
by the time Ripley and Co arrived in the
original alien movie just how much the
corporation is in league with David in
terms of making suggestions about his
warped experiments is open to questions
but we do get one final transmission
from him in the Advent scene and which
he declares ominously that if you do
this there will be no turning back my
creatures shall be set loose to rule
this galaxy so that was the Advent bonus
scene which provides a stack of new
connections to the original movies the
scene wouldn't have worked particularly
well as a final scene because it lacks
the drama of David putting Daniels into
cryo sleep just as she realizes who he
is and the reveal that David has brought
a pair of alien embryos on board however
a cut-down version of the Advent scene
could have been a really good
post-credits tag just like the prologue
scenes which weren't included in the
movie but would have made it much better
this scene would also filled in more
gaps about what David really did was
sure by the way I made a full video
about the missing prologue scenes which
you can check out by tapping the top
right of the screen Michael Fassbender's
performance as David and Walter was for
me the highlight of alien covenant and
as a longer opening scene to the movie
featuring the Android villain which
wasn't used in the final film the
opening prologue scene in the movie
depicts David's interactions with his
creator Peter Weyland just after he's
been activated the extended version adds
a little more dialogue with Weyland
asking David to explain the story behind
vogner's the entry of the gods into
Valhalla the music David chose to play
on the piano fit creator David tells the
music story about the gods rejecting
mankind as weak cruel and filled with
greed and as the gods themselves are
false and doomed to die in a cataclysmic
fire since there are as venal of as
humans they rejected and their power is
an illusion this additional commentary
feels a bit too on-the-nose about
David's opinion of people like Waylon
but it also seems a bit too obvious a
nod to the engineers and how David deals
with them later in the film likewise it
seems overly clear at ease of how David
himself would likely also become a
victim of his own hubris and a future
sequel as he becomes blinded by his
belief that he's the one who's the
perfect greater NOT Weyland or the
engineers
another change to the opening of the
movie is a deleted scene of Walter in a
green house on the covenants in the
scene Walter is busy checking on plants
in the greenhouse and has a heroes
debate with mother about whether he's
whistling to the plants to help them
grow interestingly the song we hear him
whistle is twinkle twinkle little star
which is a little Easter Eggers both
Alien Resurrection and Prometheus
features that track in its trailers or
TV spots
Walter mother's conversation is cut
short when the ship is hit by the
neutrino blast that damages it in the
theatrical release a neutrino blast
happened when Walter was checking on the
covenants human cargo in particular the
ship's human embryos and that probably
works better than including this scene
as that moment links nicely to the scene
at the end of the movie when David
smuggled in the pair of alien embryos
James Franco's Branson was unfortunately
hardly in the theatrical release of
alien covenant with his role whittled
down to a brief appearance in his cryo
chamber and then in a small video
message cameo Franco did have some
speaking lines in a prologue scene that
wasn't included in the final movie but
there was also a full deleted scene with
Branson and explored in more detail his
relationship with Daniel it's a
flashback scene where Daniels dreams
she's back in her New York apartment
together with him in the scene
Branson discusses a design of the cabin
the couple are planning to build on Ora
guy 6 in a way it's a shame this scene
didn't make it into the final film as it
would have helped the audience establish
a stronger connection to the couple and
it also reinforces exactly why the cabin
was so important to Daniel's there's an
intriguing extended clip of the Covenant
team following David across the Citadel
courtyard which is filled with the dead
bodies of the engineers as they cross
the plaza the additional scene shows the
team stopping on a long bridge over the
side of which they throw a flare as the
flare lights at what's below they see
several enormous juggernauts confirming
that the engineers clearly had multiple
ships are used for travelling to other
planets it's possible that the scene
ended up being deleted because it might
have led the covenant crew to be
suspicious about David's trustworthiness
too early on in the movie given his
claim that he was marooned when his ship
crashed and it also might have create a
confusion as to why David hadn't left
the planet there are also various other
extended and deleted scenes which don't
add an awful lot to the final film and
it's easy to see why they workers
although there are three which do show a
bit more of a bond that Walter develops
with Daniel's and hints more strongly at
the emotional connection he felt towards
her had they been included in the movie
these scenes which has extended Jacobs
funeral and the deleted Walter visits
Daniels and Daniel thanked Walter would
have shown the audience more clearly the
affection between Walter and Daniel's
and would have provided more obvious
context for the moment in the final film
when David talks about Walter's love for
Daniel's and his own for sure now what
do you think about David's tease of an
alien queen does it make you more or
less excited for the next alien prequel
movie and do let me know what you think
about the deleted scenes and any
theories you've got in the comments
below don't forget to leave a comment
answers
for a chance to win an alien covenant
funkopop and if you enjoyed this I
really appreciate your support and your
thumbs up and you can check out more of
my videos like my alien covenant
prologue scenes explained which you can
watch by tapping the screen here
congratulations to my spider-man
homecoming and my second cos 3 giveaway
winners on screen now each of you will
have received a message from me so be
sure to reply with your details so I can
send you the prize thanks for watching
and see you next time
you became movie lovers